you know I don't think I used these
exact words but I definitely intimated
in my review of a good man goes to war
that I wasn't entirely sure what
people's issues with let's kill Hitler
war I think I get it a little bit better
now
[Applause]
[Music]
all right everybody over dude Doctor Who
review and we have arrived at what is
least according to some folks including
those in my own comment section possibly
one of the worst ever episodes of Doctor
Who let's kill Hitler I don't think it's
one of the worst episodes of Doctor Who
not by a longshot but I also haven't
revisited it a long time and my memory
of it
was that it was fun and I will stand by
that it is light it is fun it is a good
watch on an entertainment level for me
at least however here's what I will
definitely grant having re-watch this
with a bit of a more critical eye than I
have in the past a lot of Moffitt's
worst habits are on display in this
episode I wouldn't say that it is an
episode entirely derived of his worst
habits but a lot of them are here and if
you wanted to play basically annoying
Moffat isms bingo you could definitely
win watching this episode so we'll get
into some of that in a little bit but
let me start with what I will stand by I
think actually works about this episode
Smith I think Matt Smith does a terrific
job in this I think he does a really
good balance of confidence of fear of
having his nice nifty little moments I
just think he does a good job Amy and
Rory do a good job River Alex Kingston
performs what she's asked to do well
we'll get a little bit into what's
actually going on with that character
but the performance is not the issue at
least I don't feel that it is there's a
fun adventure vibe to the episode
overall that in a vacuum in a bubble
looking at the episode by itself I quite
enjoy I like the lighter feel I like the
let's just lock Hitler in the cupboard
and Oh
River Song
hop on a motorcycle and tear through
Nazis cuz that sounds fun
like I I enjoy that vibe that vibe is
still a little bit of a problem they'll
be once you put it into context
especially coming off of a good man goes
to war which ended on a hopeful but very
heavy note and to pick it up with this
vibe is a little jarring and a little
weird and then there are things like the
tesselecta which is a neat idea but
brings with it a lot of problems so I
think I think we're gonna start getting
into it I don't cuz I don't have a ton
of individual positives to lay out
because the general positives I feel are
the tone is fun the performances are
good and it's not worth me pointing out
specific things but those are two
strengths that I feel run across the
episode so it's not like a good thing
happened here and then the rest is bad
know the good stuff keeps happening
across the episode but if we're gonna
look at individual elements we do have
to start talking about what doesn't
really work so let's start with Mel's
this was a neat idea poorly executed
because there's one of two things that
went on with this either Moffat didn't
have the idea that Mel's was Amy Rory's
childhood friend until very
down-to-the-wire
of this episode happening or he was so
confident in his ability to pull it off
and didn't feel the need to plant it any
earlier than this I don't know which is
the case for all intents and purposes it
doesn't really matter it will probably
be unrealistic of me to say Mel's should
have been seen as part of Amy and Rory's
life from the previous series series 5
that's probably unreasonable because I
can pretty much guarantee you the idea
hadn't been thought of then but within
the confines of series
it really should have come up we should
have seen her at some point even just to
be there like his a background during
you know segments with Amy and Rory just
establish that she's there cuz otherwise
it's a classic retcon hey here's what is
practically a third member of these
three musketeers friends that we've
never seen or even heard referenced
before up to now it suffers from classic
retcon problems which is that okay
you're telling me she's always been a
part of their lives but we've never seen
it up to this point and they can try and
establish it with this sort of series of
flashbacks which functions in terms of a
basically an exposition dump but doesn't
mean that the character suddenly works
because as far as viewers are concerned
she comes out of nowhere she just does I
will say though kind of a funny thing
that I noticed the the cornfield thing
with that they wrote doctor in the
cornfield and then Mel's drove straight
across that looked rather like the
Doctor Who logo currently being used
with the thirteenth doctor I don't know
if that was intentional or a complete
and utter coincidence but the - across
the middle made me think of that that
was kind of neat to spot but the entire
planting of Mel's is the kind of thing
that only is going to work if it's
planned and if you didn't plan it trying
to make it look like you did know you
don't sell it so that's not to say that
you can't add in some retconning
elements I mean it's not like Russell T
Davies never reckoned and Moffat has
done retcons that have worked but this
specific one requires such a leap for
how long we've known Amy and Rory and
how many little tastes of their life
without and prior to the doctor we've
gotten and she's never come up this
doesn't work it just doesn't play so
that's the first sort of Moffat ISM is
an overstep
retcon honestly in a lot of ways this
kind of this episode kind of reminds me
of the last episode of Sherlock although
it doesn't tick me off as much as the
last episode of Sherlock did but I'm
seeing a lot of the same sort of similar
stuff these sort of oh and it goes back
so far it's like yeah but you're only
telling me this now I spent all these
time with these characters so no I don't
buy that so there's your first Moffat
ISM the other one the Moffat has a
tendency to get criticized for his
female characters now I'm not gonna say
I'm necessarily a defender of the way he
writes female characters I will say that
his approach sometimes works sometimes
doesn't his approach tends to be very
flirty a bit some might even argue over
sexualized as a default for a lot of his
female characters and it's a pattern
that he kind of needed to break which at
least for me was a big part of why Bill
was such a breath of fresh air in series
10 but with someone like wherever song
it has worked up to this point with
their garage or at least I feel it I
felt like it worked up to this point
because that sort of flirty nature with
the doctor specifically very much leant
into the idea of she's got a history
with him that he doesn't know we don't
fully know and this flirting is an
aspect of that and there are other
Moffat characters that I feel are flirty
but it feels grounded in them as opposed
to a template stamped on them I actually
feel that way about Amy quite strongly I
feel like her flirtier elements are very
grounded in her character and Karen
Gillan sells them as an actual element
of her as a person as opposed to just an
affectation here though we're getting
mel's transitioning into River and
immediately doing the flirty the
possibly even harder than she ever has
before
thing and here way more than I ever did
before
it feels like an affectation and again
maybe if we had known Mel's as a
character prior to this that transition
might have
worked but instead we basically have a
character who we don't know suddenly
become a character we do know who's
behaving in a way that when we've seen
it before
felt like it depended on a heavy amount
of history but our basically coming in
to more or less the birth of that
character especially when you take into
account that regeneration was a certain
amount of personality shifts that just
means that River is massively flirty as
soon as she is born effectively and
there's something a little off-putting
about that there's something a little
bit like oh that's not like she found
herself and chooses to be that way it's
almost like this is an automatic
inherent part of her person it's it's
baked into her she can't be any other
way I'm trying mm maybe it kind of makes
me do that a little bit the tesselecta
is an interesting idea on paper that I
don't think fits in the world of Doctor
Who I think it's too big of an app an
idea basically I think one of the things
especially that modern doctor who has
had a tendency to do is have too many
forces be they individuals or races or
agencies or whatever who basically can
more or less do what the doctor does but
maybe just aren't as good at it aren't
guided by the same moral guidelines or
what-have-you but it is feeling like
there's a few too many overpowered
elements floating around in this
universe at this point I mean with the
amount of time travel the Daleks are now
capable of what the silence appear to be
capable of
later on we'll even have one-off things
like I actually thought it was a neat
idea but the sort of glass memory
containment thing in twice upon a time
is a neat idea but it's so big that it's
like is that an idea that's is that too
much for this universe and I feel that a
little bit about the tesselecta because
the very concept of
going and pulling people from their
timelines in order to punish them first
of all it just strikes me as a very odd
use of technology you're gonna punish
people who are already dead
I'm not gonna say there's no validation
and that particularly if they're truly
dealing with some of the worst of the
worst but really that's the best thing
you could think to do with a
time-traveling robot that can change his
face that's all you've got
it's it it makes the the tesselecta crew
and whoever the heck it is they actually
work for it's like the Justice Center I
can't even remember now but it makes
them both overpowered and very petty
which on paper is not automatically a
mix that doesn't go together I actually
kind of enjoy at times when it's well
executed and when this element is part
of what is being explored an individual
or group who is way pettier than they're
then what they are capable of should
mean like they're capable of all this
they should be thinking big picture but
they're so petty and they're down here
that can totally work but that's not
really what they're going for here it's
just kind of there as an element in the
background the miniaturised people I'm
okay with it's a bit goofy it's a bit
silly but I I do kind of enjoy that you
know a crew of people inside all these
people working to move the thing around
and everything the antibodies are
functional their little needless and
also like I will always kind of call BS
on any security system that kills
everything you know unless except for X
like their default is if they see it
they kill it I'm like that's gonna
backfire on you I know it is immediately
that's clearly what's gonna happen it's
not like they play it as a twist it's
set up like very early on that that can
and likely will happen but it just makes
it a bit trite bit lazy and I think
that's part of the thing I think this
part of the clash with this episode as
far as its place in the overall scope of
this series and of the journeys of the
characters involved River Amy Rory the
doctor this is a big important life
defining life-changing series of events
treated and handled very flippantly very
casually with a little bit of camp and I
think there's a real distinct clash of
tone there in terms of the gravity of
what is going on and the way that it is
handled mood and tone they don't mesh
they don't gel and there are ways to
make that work because sometimes the
most important things in your life don't
feel momentous at the time that is the
thing that can happen except this still
tries to have it be momentous at certain
moments like at the very end with River
granting her generations to the doctor
it you you don't the gear shifts the
total gear shifts don't work and they're
clashing right off the get-go so yeah
Wow I still I will maintain that I am
personally of the opinion that this
episode is overrated I get it a bit
better now as to why people don't really
like it and some people really don't
like it and again if if you want to
point to some of the weaknesses or bad
habits that Moffat has as a writer this
is huh that's a very good example to
cite let's kill Hitler what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to do
buttons links I've got a tip jar if you
feel like supporting me in a sort of
one-off fashion I've also got a patreon
if you feel like supporting me in an
ongoing fashion links to both of those
are down in the description you can
share this all that sort of stuff other
links besides check out what's down
there or don't you don't have to because
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]